en selle peut-être même et spirit il que
le peuple de france ne serait pas au
rendez vous et le peuple de france est
venu puisque le peuple de france il a le
peuple français venus de tous les
quartiers de paris de toute
l'ile-de-france de toutes les provinces
de toutes les villes est même venue de
nos territoires d'outre-mer j'ai donné
rendez-vous à halle en france que l'on
entend jamais parce qu'on ne donne
jamais la parole
j'ai donné rendez-vous à la france qui
affronte les difficultés de la vie sans
jamais rien demandé parce qu'elle a trop
de fierté j'ai donné rendez-vous à la
france qu'ils souffrent sont jamais se
plaindre parce qu'elle a trop de pudeur
je donne rendez-vous à la france qui ne
protestent pas à la france qui ne casse
pas et à la france qu'ils ont assez que
l'on parle en son nom avec des idées qui
ne sont pas les siennes
et des profondeurs du pays la france
silencieuse a répondu par votre présence
sur cette place dont le nom exprime la
volonté de toute une nation de surmonter
les épreuves qu'ils ont déchiré et qui
ont fait couler tant de sang et de
larmes
les coeurs des dizaines de milliers de
français qui se trouvent rassemblés sur
cette place battent à l'unisson des
coeurs des millions de français qui dans
toutes les villes et dans tous les
villages de france s'interroge avec
inquiétude sur l'avenir de la france
c'est balla parts l'italien qui a le
mieux parlé de ce lieu la concorde où
commencent et finissent depuis deux
siècles
toutes nos tragédies nationales la place
de la concorde dit il est une idée ce
n'est pas une place c'est une manière de
penser tout ce qui est vraiment français
se mesurent ici et bien la vague immense
qui submerge aujourd'hui le coeur de
paris
porte cette idée de la france comme une
irrésistible espérances vous êtes la
france
[Applaudissements]
c'est ce même mal à part
c'est ce même italien qui nous connaît
si bien qui a dit l'italien considère
l'histoire comme un caprice fut-il un
caprice des dieux l'anglais comme un
fait de la nature
mais le français considère l'histoire
comme un chef de la volonté des hommes
cette volonté française de faire
l'histoire pour ne pas la subir
c'est cette volonté là même qui vous a
conduit ici sur la place de la concorde
vous n'êtes pas là seulement pour vous
même vous êtes les représentants de tous
ceux qui n'ont pas pu venir mais qu'ils
veulent espérer en la france vous êtes
les porte parole de ceux qui n'ont
jamais la parole de ceux qui ne demande
jamais rien de ce qu'ils sont fiers de
la france fière de sa culture
fier de sa longue fier de son identité
fière de ce qu'elle a accompli dans son
histoire et de ceux qui n'en peuvent
plus du dénigrement systématique de
notre pays de sa culpabilisation et que
l'on se permette de mettre en cause la
france à la moindre occasion le peuple
de france dit ça suffit
vous êtes au fond les témoins ceux qui
maintiennent vivante la parole et la
pensée quand la parole est confisqué et
quand la pensée est interdite
vous êtes les témoins ce qui oppose un
lassabe le mans la vérité à la
répétition du mensonge
jusqu'à ce que la vérité finisse par
triompher du mensonge
beaucoup parmi vous je le sais ne sont
pas engagés peut-être s'imaginait-il ne
jamais le faire
ils sont venus parce qu'ils pensent à
leur avenir et à celui de leurs enfants
parce qu'ils ont acquis l'intimé
conviction que quelque chose d'essentiel
est en jeu aujourd'hui et parce qu'une
inquiétude les saisies quand ils
entendent le tumulte du monde quand il
voit les épreuves auxquelles sont
confrontés tour à tour des pays qui nous
sont si proches
le 22 avril et le 6 mai il ne s'agira
pas mes chers compatriotes de choisir un
camp il s'agira de décider pour l'avenir
un moment historique où l'avenir de
notre pays se joue c'est pourquoi je
veux aussi parler à ces millions de
français une histoire personnelle ou
familiale n'attache pas un parti je veux
parler à cette majorité silencieuse qui
une fois encore tient le destin de la
france dans ses mains je veux lui dire
qu'au milieu des crises les plus
dangereuses que le monde ait connues
depuis un demi siècle
une seule chose doit compter aujourd'hui
où voulons nous aller nous les français
jamais sans doute depuis la fin de la
deuxième guerre mondiale
les choix que nous avons affaire n'ont
été aussi lourd de conséquences je sais
que beaucoup de nos compatriotes qu'il
souffre ont envie de crier leur
souffrance de crier leur colère en
votant pour les extrêmes je comprends la
douleur de ceux que la crise a fait
souffrir mais les solutions extrêmes
n'attirerait pas leur douleur
les solutions extrêmes ne protégerait
pas les français
elle ne leur apporterait aucune aide
elle ne ferait souffrir davantage car
les solutions extrêmes sont des
mensonges et les mensonges font toujours
davantage de mal que la vérité voilà la
vérité de la france dans l'otan
je comprends l'envi
[Applaudissements]
je comprends l'envi de dire non à tout
pour ceux qui ont le sentiment si
désespérant d'être dépossédés d'avoir
perdu le contrôle de leur vie la
maîtrise de leur destin
je comprends le sentiment d'injustice de
celui qui n'arrive pas à vivre de son
travail quand d'autres y parviennent
sans travail et je comprends ce qu'il y
à d'insupportable pour celui à qui on
demande des sacrifices et qui voit ceux
qui sont responsables de cette crise
continue à prospérer
je comprends le désarroi d'une jeunesse
qui regardent avec anxiété le chômage
lui barrer la route
la planète s'épuiser et la montagne des
dettes qu'elle devra payer un jour
si nous ne prenons pas les bonnes
décisions mais dans la situation se
trouve la france où se trouve l'europe
où se trouve le monde nul vous
m'entendez bien nul ne peut espérer
dissocier son destin personnel de celui
de tous
nul ne peut espérer s'en sortir seul
alors je suis allé à la rencontre des
français que demande-t-il
il demande la justice ils demandent la
liberté
ils demandent l'espoir la justice qui
est dans l'équilibré des droits et des
devoirs
la liberté qui permet à chacun d'écrire
sa propre histoire et l'espoir qui fait
reculer la peur de l'avenir
mais comment répondre à cette triple
aspirations si délibérément on tourne le
dos à la réalité du monde
comment répondre si délibérément on fait
semblant d'être seuls au monde
comment affronter des crises dont on se
refuserait à reconnaître l'existence et
comment relever des défis
que l'on ne voudrait pas regarder en
face c'est en affrontant les difficultés
que l'on peut les surmonter
pas en les niant notre époque réclame
autre chose que l'outrance des uns ou le
déni des autres voilà pourquoi je veux
faire campagne sur la vérité car seule
la vérité permettra
la raison
m
[Applaudissements]
alors face à la montée des périls et
vous vous souviendrez de ce que vous
avez vécu sur cette place face à la
montée des périls qui nous menacent il
faut de la solidité et il faut de la
gravité la situation de l'europe et
l'état du monde ne nous laisse aucun
droit à l'erreur
la france n'a pas le droit à l'erreur
mes chers compatriotes c'est une course
contre la montre qui est engagée avec au
bout le risque de la crise économique de
la désintégration sociale et par dessus
tout le risque du déclin de l'humanisme
les crises qui se sont succédé depuis
quatre ans sont des avertissements que
le monde doit entendre
je veux le dire avec gravité ce qui est
en jeu c'est ni plus ni moins que la
survie d'une forme de civilisation la
nôtre dans un monde où la passion
exclusive pour les gains du court terme
et les crispations identitaires
s'affrontent de plus en plus violemment
préparant si l'on ne prend pas les
bonnes décisions
les grandes tragédies du futur comme à
l'orée de la renaissance des lumières ou
de la révolution industrielle
nous n'avons pas le droit nous les
français de manquer notre entrée dans
l'ère nouvelle que préparent les
bouleversements d'aujourd'hui si nous ne
voulons pas prendre le risque de perdre
notre agriculture nos usines nos emplois
notre art de vivre notre façon d'aimer
de penser notre culture notre
littérature notre langue
tout ce à quoi nous tenons tous ceux
donc quoi nous avons mis tout le génie
de la france depuis des siècles alors
nous n'avons pas le droit de biaiser et
nous devons tirer les conséquences de
ces crises terribles que le monde vient
de connaître
nous les français nous avons réussi un
miracle 66 millions d'individus
farouchement
individualiste sont arrivés à former une
seule et même personne dont le génie
singulier n'a cessé depuis des siècles
d'éclairer l'humanité c'est ce même pays
ce même génie français qui doit
s'interroger aujourd'hui
où voulons nous aller et la direction
dépendra du choix historique que vous
devez prendre dans la semaine
[Applaudissements]
je crois
à
des plus profond de mon âme j'ai
toujours pensé que la france ce n'était
pas seulement le nom d'un pays
j'ai toujours pensé que la france s'est
elle non d'une civilisation quand on
entend la france on entend molière on
entend voltaire on entend châteaubriant
la france n'est pas un pays comme les
autres
le choix que vous allez faire est un
foie qui portera dans le monde entier
oui quand j'entends le mot france
j'entends la prière de péguy à
notre-dame de sharp 2000 ans de labeur
ont fait de cette terre la france
un réservoir sans fin pour les âges
nouveau voilà l'ère nouvelle et la
responsabilité de la france
péguy
raison quand on parle de la france
on entend liberté égalité fraternité
quand on parle de la france on entend le
cri de valmy on entend la grande
révolution dix ans au monde
le bonheur est une idée neuve parce que
le bonheur est une idée française
on entend la voix de napoléon dictant le
bulletin de victoire au soleil
d'austerlitz
on entend le nom du général de gaulle le
18 juin
on entend la voix d'aimé césaire la voix
d'aimé césaire ce grand poète goethe ans
racines zola et victor hugo à la figure
des censeurs de vichy nous sommes les
héritiers de cette france là rien n'y
oblige
cette fausse nous n'avons pas le droit
ici place de la concorde dollis et
dilapidé l'héritage de la france
éternelle
nous les français nous ne voulons pas de
la facilité du renoncement de la
mollesse parce que ce ne sont pas des
défauts qui sont dans les gènes de la
france
alors on pourrait se dire après tout la
france en a tant vu la france a survécu
à tant d'épreuves qu'au fond elle ne
risque rien mais si la france a survécu
c'est parce qu'à chaque fois qu'elle
s'est trouvée confrontée à de grandes
échéances
elle a su dans un ultime effort venu des
profondeurs du pays
rassembler toutes ses forces pour
changer le cours du destin
ce soir j'ai besoin que vous rassembler
toutes vos forces de la france
puis la france forte pour moi c'est la
france de valmy c'est la france de la
résistance de la france 2 jean monnet
[Applaudissements]
blocher amiens
les voies de l'avenir les voies de
l'avenir nous les connaissons la société
de la connaissance
l'économie du savoir la révolution
numérique
la réponse au défi de l'écologie
l'adaptation notre appareil productif et
des organisations sociales à
l'épuisement des énergies fossiles à la
lente et inexorable disparition du
pétrole et à la non moins inexorable
augmentation de son prix c'est un
immense effort de formation de recherche
d'innovation d'investissement qui attend
la france c'est toute la croissance de
demain
c'est toute la qualité de vie de demain
qui vont dépendre de cet effort que nous
allons engager
nous avons la jeunesse nous avons
l'intelligence
nous avons les savants nous avons les
entrepreneurs pour inventer ce nouveau
modèle de croissance
ce nouveau modèle français du 21e siècle
ce nouveau modèle français il répondra
aux besoins de justice parce qu'il ne
sera pas soumis à la dictature de la
finance à sa tyrannie de la rentabilité
à court terme parce que tout le monde
sera formé parce que tout le monde
pourra accéder à la promotion sociale
par l'instruction et par la formation
dans ce nouveau modèle français
l'école s'obligera être attentive à la
fragilité des enfants et nous
n'accepterons plus aucun élève au
collège qu'ils ne sachent lire écrire et
compter
dans ce nouveau
des français chaque jeune qui choisira
l'alternance trouvera une place dans les
entreprises les chômeurs auront le droit
à la formation mais ils seront aussi un
devoir celui d'accepter l'emploi qu'on
leur proposera dans ce nouveau modèle
français
chacun pourra reprendre la maîtrise de
son destin se sentir libre de choisir
son rythme de vie se sentir pleinement
responsable de soi même dans ce nouveau
modèle français tout le monde rôle droit
à une deuxième chance et toute famille
de bonne foi confronté un accident de la
vie dont la conséquence est le
surendettement pourra comme une
entreprise bénéficier de la faillite
civile tels que cela existe en alsace
afin de redémarrer dans la vie parce que
aucun échec
aucun échec dans ce nouveau modèle
français ne doit être définitif dans ce
nouveau modèle français
je veux qu'on récompense l'effort le
mérite le travail
moi je ne veux pas d'une france qui
dénonce le talent qui n'aime pas la
réussite et qui a peur du succès la
jalousie l'envi l'amertume ne sont pas
et ne seront jamais des valeurs
françaises je ne vous
je n'accepterai jamais une france
niveler égalitariste qui tournerait le
dos aux talents parce qu'elle aurait
peur la france qui n'aiment pas le
talent c'est une transe faible
[Applaudissements]
alors mes chers amis je vous propose de
réunir les conditions pour que la france
organise les trente glorieuses du xxième
siècle comme elle a connu les trente
glorieuses du 20e je vous propose de
relever un défi celui qui consiste à
renouveler l'exploit car ce fut un
exploit qu'ont accompli les hommes de
l'après-guerre qui avait si bien tiré
les leçons des grandes fautes du passé
et des tragédies qu'elle avait engendré
ce que je vous propose c'est de
mobiliser toutes les forces
intellectuelles morales sociales de la
nation c'est de rendre la parole au
peuple
quand les corporatismes et les
conservatismes se lit pour empêcher le
pays d'avancer
nous ne les laisserons pas nous
condamner à l'immobilisme
je vous propose de déconstruire l'état
bureaucratique pour reconstruire un état
entrepreneur qu'il soit une force
d'entraînement je vous propose de
remplacer le capitalisme financier par
un capitalisme d'entrepreneur nous ne
voulons plus qu'une infime minorité des
voix
les idées qui sont les nôtres par des
comportements inacceptables
voilà notre vie
je vous propose un état qui réduit ses
dépenses qui refuse la drogue de la
dépense publique qui remet de l'ordre
dans ses finances pour préparer l'avenir
et pour investir la condition c'est
l'unité nationale moi je veux parler au
peuple de france pas la gauche pas la
droite
je veux parler aux citoyens libres de
mon pays en leur disant de laisser les
chaînes de l'habitude de côté et de ne
se poser une seule question quel avenir
voulez vous pour votre pays voilà la
seule question libyenne
alors où il nous faut affronter les
conséquences de la crise je vous le dis
à
[Applaudissements]
les goûts locaux avec l'expérience de
ces cinq dernières années
ce serait une folie d'affaiblir notre
modèle républicain
nous n'accepterons jamais le
communautarisme et tout ce qui va avec
nous avons besoin de cohésion et je
n'accepterai jamais qu'on veut le
détruire les institutions qui fondent la
république je parle de l'école et je
parle de la famille voilà ce que nous
n'accepterons jamais l'école parce que
l'école elle appartient aux familles de
france pas aux organisations syndicales
qui n'ont que le mot statut à la bouche
la famille parce qu'ici en france on
sait bien que la vie peut être cruel et
quand la vie est cruelle et que chacun
doit mettre un genou à terre
il a sa famille derrière lui la famille
en france c'est sacré nous ne la
laisserons pas la décrire
bonjour il ne s'agit pas de rassembler
les français pour qu'ils se ferment au
monde
au contraire nous devons être assez fort
pour ne pas avoir peur de l'ouverture au
monde
jamais je ne plaiderai le repliement
mais nous avons commis une erreur
pendant 30 ans en passant la nation par
pertes et profits alors que dans la
mondialisation partout regarder autour
de nous ce sont les nations qui tiennent
le premier rang parce qu'elles sont
portés par un élan collectif qui leur
donne une force irrésistible dans la
compétition mondiale dans la compétition
mondiale les pays qui réussiront sont
les pays
kata seront du prix à l'idée de nation
la nation refaire fait l'avenir de la
france
nous avons eu le tort de négliger les
frontières thor d'élargir et d'ouvrir
nos marchés sans contrepartie tort de
laisser la bureaucratie prendre le pas
sur la volonté politique tort de bâtir
une europe de la consommation sans se
soucier de l'europe de la production car
le jour où le consommateur est au
chômage
je me demande bien qu'est ce qui peut
consommer si les frontières extérieures
de l'europe ne sont pas protégés contre
les concurrences déloyales contre les
dumpings contre l'immigration
incontrôlée
alors il n'y aura pas de modèle français
et n'y aura plus de civilisation
européenne
si nous avons fait l'europe c'est pour
être protégé pas pour laisser détruire
notre identité et notre civilisation
jeudi
ma détermination à faire changer
l'europe sur la question des frontières
les chers amis j'irai jusqu'au bout
j'irai jusqu'à suspendre s'il le faut
les accords de schengen et à rétablir
des contrôles ciblés
j'irai jusqu'à impliquer s'il le faut à
nos marchés publics les règles
s'appliquent les américains en accordant
leurs attributions qu'aux seules
entreprises qui produiront sur le
continent européen
si on ne veut pas produire et créer de
l'emploi sur le continent européen
on n'a pas besoin d'être candidats aux
marchés publics du continent européen
voilà notre vérité je rebondis je
revendique pour la france le droit de
choisir qui elle accepte sur son
territoire je revendique pour la france
le droit de se protéger contre la
concurrence de ceux qui ne respectent
aucune règle
je revendique pour la france le droit de
mettre en oeuvre des politiques
industrielles et de réserver une partie
des marchés publics aux pme
je revendique pour la france le droit de
défendre ses valeurs sa culture sa
langue son modèle républicain et son
identité qui n'est pas un bon mot parce
que défendent
son identité défendre sa civilisation
ce n'est pas en deux c'est légitime
quand on oublie d'où l'on vient et qu'il
en est comment peut-on savoir où l'on va
la défense de ses droits c'est ce que la
france attend de l'europe
c'est ce que la france demande à
l'europe mais la france le dit à ses
partenaires elle ne renoncera jamais à
les défendre elle même si l'europe ne
les défend pas je veux aller plus loin
encore
après ce que nous avons fait pour sauver
l'euro je veux poser non seulement le
problème des frontières mais aussi celui
du rôle de la banque centrale dans le
soutien à la croissance
c'est une question très important que
nous ne pourrons pas éludée si le rap ne
veut pas perdre pied dans l'économie
mondiale elle doit absolument renouer
avec la croissance mais la croissance
cela ne se décrète pas il ne suffit pas
d'écrire le mot croissance dans un
traité pour l'obtenir
si l'on ne fait rien pour la
compétitivité
si on alourdit le coût du travail s'ils
ont découragé esprit d'entreprise
si l'on n'investit pas ce n'est pas la
croissance que l'on n'obtient c'est la
stagnation si l'on ne change pas
l'europe si l'on ne fait pas l'europe de
la production l'europe de
l'investissement nous n'aurons pas la
croissance si la banque centrale ne
soutient pas la croissance
nous n'aurons pas assez de croissance la
crise et l'européen convaincu que je
suis veut le dire nous a montré les
limites des règles qui ont été fixées
dans le traité de maastricht
je sais les difficultés d'aborder ce
sujet je connais les obstacles mais je
dis nous avons le devoir de réfléchir à
cette question parce que cette question
est un problème majeur pour l'avenir de
l'europe
c'est un problème stratégique pour
l'europe l'europe doit apurer ses dettes
elle n'a pas le choix
mais entre la déflation et la croissance
l'europe n'a pas davantage le choix
parce que si l'europe choisi la
déflation alors l'europe dise
petra souvenons nous des années 30 si
les français me font confiance
j'ouvrirai ce débat et je mettrai la
même énergie
vous m'entendez la même détermination à
faire avancer l'europe de la croissance
l'europe qui investit dans son avenir
que celle que j'ai mise à combattre la
crise financière et à sauver l'euro le
client mes amis quel que soit votre
engagement
il n'y a pas de sujet tabou il n'y a pas
de débat interdit on nous avait dit que
la banque centrale ne pourrait pas
intervenir pour sauver l'euro souvient
temps françois souvient tôt alain et la
banque centrale s'est donné la liberté
nécessaire pour sauver l'euro en
fournissant les liquidités aux banques
ce qui était un tabou
devant la crise est tombée comme une
frontière de papier on nous avait dit
que le gouvernement économique c'était
impossible et nous avons obtenu le
gouvernement et économique
on nous avait dit que la question des
frontières était tabou et nous avons
posé la question des frontières
on nous avait dit que le débat sur la
réciprocité était interdite et nous
avons ouvert le débat sur la réciprocité
alors sur le rôle de la banque centrale
européenne dans le soutien à la
croissance
nous allons nous les français ouvrir le
débat et nous allons faire avancer
l'europe
dans le général de gaulle
dans le général de gaulle au milieu des
années 60 a posé la question de la
politique agricole commune et qu'il n'a
pas été entendu
il n'a pas hésité à faire la politique
de la chaise vide
on l'a accusée de détruire l'europe
alors qu'à ce moment là
par cette politique là il a construit
l'europe pour les décennies qui allait
suivre mes chers compatriotes c'est à
votre coeur et à votre raison que je
veux m'adresser enfin à votre coeur
parce que ce qui nous réunit ici c'est
l'amour de la france à votre raison
parce qu'il faut que le choix soit clair
et que ses conséquences soient comprises
deux voies sont finalement possible
l'une imposera les solutions du passé
au mieux elle ne résoudra rien
puisqu'elle restera prisonnière de tous
les conservatismes
elle continuera à laisser les frontières
s'effacent et et la nation s'affaiblit
au pire elle découragera la réussite
l inra les classes moyennes sont pour
autant enrichir les plus pauvres elle
détruira la confiance des investisseurs
elle nous mettra la merci de la
spéculation et pour s'en sortir
elle imposera au final l'austérité la
plus dure qui plongera le pays dans la
dépression l'autre voix c'est celle qui
sera tourné vers l'avenir
je vous propose de tirer les leçons des
crises et d'inventer les solutions du
21e siècle
je vous propose de construire un nouveau
modèle de croissance
une nouvelle ambition sociale une
nouvelle économie
entre le nationalisme et le laissait
faire je vous propose pour la nation la
voie raisonnable de l'unité et de
l'ouverture au monde la vocation de la
france n'est pas de s'effacer ou de se
taire la vocation de la france et d'agir
pour ceux qui ne peuvent pas agir
la vocation de la france et de parler
pour ceux qui ne peuvent pas parler
c'est d'être aux côtés des peuples qui
veulent être libres et notamment d'être
aux côtés des chrétiens d'orient
quand ils sont persécutés la vocation de
la france c'est d'organiser autour de la
méditerranée une communauté de destin la
france est intervenue pour protéger le
peuple libyen du massacre
la france prendra des initiatives au
moyen-orient pour que la paix et la
justice triomphe enfin la france portera
la régulation de la mondialisation la
moralisation de la finance
la taxation des transactions financières
pour dégager les ressources dans les
pays pauvres ont besoin pour sortir de
la misère
la vocation de la france au fond c'est
d'être le porte parole de tous ceux qui
dans le monde exige que l'homme ne soit
pas sacrifié au commerce que le droit du
travail de la santé de l'environnement
soit mis à égalité avec le droit du
commerce
par delà les siècles la grande voix de
victor hugo nous dit le programme de
l'avenir
écoutez le grand écrivain une liberté
sans usurpation et sans violence une
égalité qui admettra la croissance
naturelle de chacun une fraternité
d'hommes libres
l'application du principe qui veut que
tout homme commence par le travail et
finissent par la propriété le respect de
l'héritage
qui n'est autre chose que la main du
père tendue aux enfants à travers le mur
du tombeau l'ordre comme loi des
citoyens la paix comme loi des nations
voilà ce que ce grand français victor
hugo disait il n'ya rien à changer
il n'y a rien à retirer c'est cette
france là dont nous voulons être les
hérité alors mes chers compatriotes
entendez mon appel la france de victor
hugo et du général de gaulle la france
qui regarde vers l'avenir
la france qui choisit le progrès la
france qui veut se mettre au service de
toute l'humanité
cette rousse c'est votre france mes
chers compatriotes
prenez votre destin en main déchets vous
prenez la parole
dites ce que vous avez sur le coeur qui
ce que vous voulez pour votre pays dit
le haut dit le faut dès que maintenant
n'ayez pas peur
peuple de france n'ayez pas peur ils ne
gagneront pas si vous décidez que vous
voulez gagner
venez chez un ami depuis trente ans que
je me suis engagé au service de la
france
j'ai fait une longue route celle là même
qui m'a mené jusqu'à vous jusqu'à la
dernière minute de cette campagne
j'irai à votre rencontre chaque minute
chaque seconde pour convaincre pour
parler de la france pour soulever le
peuple de france
temple de france entend mon appel
française procès et des mois et des mois
et la france
[Applaudissements]
moncef c'est maintenant c'est qu'ici
place ratant co vive la république et
vive la france
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]